ich hatte euch ja versprochen in zukunft
mehr über schwarze löcher zu machen
wir haben ja schon auf bilder
animationen oder grafiken von schwarzen
löchern hier gezeigt aber das waren
immer nur vorstellungen davon wie ein
schwarzes loch aussehen könnte aber kein
schwarzes loch ist uns so nah dass wir
wirklich zeigen könnten aber das wird
sich bald ändern große steht uns bevor
oder besser absolut riesiges herzlich
willkommen die pixum 26
schon oft haben wir schwarze löcher
hierbei gezeigt aber das waren im
prinzip nur fantasiegebilde so stellen
sich wissenschaftler schwarze löcher vor
und haben abbildung auf grund ihrer
daten und untersuchungen erstellt also
auf wissenschaftlicher basis schon aber
das ist schon verrückt alle reden über
dieses phänomen aber niemand hat bisher
ein schwarzes loch gesehen dass
wahrscheinlich realistisches abbild
wurde im kinofilm interstellar gezeigt
dazu habe ich extra ein video gemacht
und durch die raumzeit krümmung
erscheint dort die aktions scheibe über
dem schwarzen loch obwohl sie eigentlich
dahinter liegt das ist schon mein klo
aber wie sehen sie nun wirklich aus wie
hier auf der erde haben nicht den
blassesten schimmer
aber das soll sich nun ändern dafür wird
jetzt das größte radioteleskop der welt
eingesetzt das event reisen tel
es ist so ist ja fast so groß wie die
erde geben darf ganz einfach nicht ganz
einfach aber genial
die wissenschaftler haben weltweit
teleskope zusammengeschaltet und sind
jetzt endlich in der lage das große
schwarze loch im zentrum unserer galaxie
der milchstraße zu fotografieren
mit diesem größten fotoapparat der welt
soll jetzt ein bild von sagittarius
gemacht werden so heißt das schwarze
loch im zentrum die herausforderung ins
enthält 24 millionen sonnenmassen aber
der eigene horizont ist nur so groß wie
die umlaufbahn des merkurs um die sonne
dabei ist es 26 tausend lichtjahre von
der erde entfernt das bedeutet quasi die
spitze einer stecknadel in einigen
kilometern entfernung zu fotografieren
und dann ist es auch noch ein schwarzes
loch es selbst ist unsichtbar
die forscher hoffen dass die gasströme
abbilden können bevor sie hinter dem
ereignishorizont verschwinden ist quasi
ihr letztes aufflackern vor ihrem
verschwinden festgehalten zwischen dem
fünften und 14 april sollen die
aufnahmen gemacht werden dafür wurden
zahlreiche teleskope weltweit mit
detektoren in feiner 30 gigahertz
bereich ausgestattet
20 jahre haben die vorbereitungen dafür
gedauert
die daten werden dann im mgh
observatorium in weblogs
zusammengeführt einmal steht dabei für
massachusetts institute of technology
bis allerdings erste aufnahmen zu sehen
sein werden müssen wir uns etwas
gedulden die wissenschaftler rechnet mit
ersten ergebnissen erst 2018 diese
ersten foto wenn man natürlich hier bei
pixum zeigen
ich bin mega gespannt wenn ihr das und
mehr nicht verpassen wollte drückt mir
ein abo darauf augen und haut ihn auf
die glocke hier geht es unserer place zu
schwarzen löchern einfach draufklicken
bis das blatt